[Music]
an experience only music can fully
Express
[Music]
the naked Humanity of War
[Music]
front line by anti-tilla one of the
biggest bands out of Ukraine
[Music]
they're now back in the studio
rehearsing the song they made with Ed
Sheeran
[Music]
you but still disoriented by the
conflict we are fathers we are husbands
also we have some dreams some we had
some plans and the world changed
everything and I cannot say
to be frankly
it is not so easy but we must do this we
must live this dual life
they served as Medics until they were
pardoned by the Ukrainian military in
August tasked instead to serve solely
through their art they're back home but
their families are still displaced by
the war and live abroad when he hugs
your wives hugs your kids when you're
making something
um
funny things with them conversating with
them but even but if you only has like
this window
fortunately we have internet connection
we have this window we can somehow to
connect with them and a lot of people a
lot of families this war separated a lot
of families
one of the oldest hip-hop groups in the
country are also continuing their
service in the studio
[Music]
tnmk are producing an informational
video to go with their new single
this one is about the dangers of
shelling and mines people who wouldn't
normally support the military
institution why do you think they put
aside these feelings to to get to go to
the front line and fight
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Global solidarity with the Ukrainian
cause has come to life on International
stages through song collaborations
music carrying their message across the
world
[Music]
Sky News Kiev